faisons une comparaison avec un pays
géographiquement proches de la chine la
corée du sud
faisons la comparaison avec un autre
pays le japon est ce que ces pays qui
sont démocratiques des formes de
démocratie d'ailleurs diverses
parce que la démocratie oui c'est la
liberté
enfin payer va bien différentes formes
de démocratie d'organisation
institutionnelle
donc est ce que le japon et la corée du
sud ça marche vraiment plus mal que la
chine était dans ma bouche c'est une
question complètement créé toriques je
ne le pense pas du tout je pense même
que ça marche beaucoup mieux et pour ma
part si on me proposait de vivre soit en
chine soit en corée du sud soit au japon
ben je préfèrerait certainement là que
la corée du sud et le japon est plutôt
la corée du sud que le japon encore
alors écoutez nord vous posiez la
question à l'instant et monsieur canal
la pause et aussi de l'originalité du
système chinois
je ne pense pas du tout en effet comme
comme lui comme madame excusez moi votre
nom et chocolat je vous demande pardon
je ne pense pas du tout qu'ils aient
inventé
quoique ce soit ils ont simplement
additionner la brutalité d'un
capitalisme sauvage à la brutalité
réitéré comme on viens de l'entendre
depuis maintenant trois quatre ans à la
brutalité réitérée du parti unique et du
système communiste
c'est à dire que finalement ce pays a
rapporté c'est vrai d'ailleurs d'europe
absolument absolument ce qu'il ya de
pire dans le capitalisme est ce qu'il ya
de pire dans le communisme
[Musique]